we uh post who's going to be on and we
suggest if you want to talk we talk to
our viewers if you want to talk to Rob
and uh are you okay with taking a phone
call sure all right Rob rigle is here um
he is an actor a comedian a geographic
Bachelor um and do you hear it yes this
is a call they know that you're on so
let's
see hello can you hear hello yes this is
RO you are talking to Rob rle what is
your name sir hi my name is Derek hi
Derek hi Derek are you a fan of Rob Rob
rle yes sir no I'm how oh that's Rob
I'll let him talk go ahead oh gosh Rob I
have been trying so hard to get a hold
of you I've been trying I've sent you
um quite a few DMS actually I've really
been well don't take it personally I
don't check I don't check my time
actually I don't check my
DMs so I know you're a huge Kansas City
fan um my name I'm from I'm from Dallas
I uh one time my buddy Eric he uh we're
electricians here in Dallas he uh shout
out Eric he's awesome um we
uh it was wait let's take a moment let's
take a moment now uh shout out to ER 19
wait wait Derek shout out to Eric shout
out Eric all electricians in Dallas yeah
2019 uh go to Hoy mandel.com for all the
electronics all the electricians in uh
in if you want Hoy merch go to Hoy
mandel.com yeah in the Greater Dallas
Fort Worth area but yes okay yeah right
go ahead Derek yeah it was you're
talking to Rob 2019 or was it
2020 no because that was
Co um I think it was probably Co is when
he uh Rob stopped his uh we drove from
Dallas to Kansas City to uh we went to
go see the Chiefs play the Cowboys game
uh I'm not really a big fan of football
sometimes I'll sometimes I'll watch it
with my dad shout out my dad he rules um
You probably like him what you're
assuming Rob thinks your your dad is
dead no no shout out let shout out no
you looked up I do that's is your dad
dead my dad's not dead no no no he's
he's still he's with us all right keep
going Derek all right good
we watch football sometimes I'm not a
huge football fan but got it my my buddy
Eric uh he had tickets to go see and I I
wanted to go
specifically just hoping that you were
there so that I can uh maybe meet you
and ask you a question and stuff well
it's nice to nice to talk to you now so
what's your question um my question is
what's are on a grande
like why would you ask because I I did a
uh when she was on on a TV show called
uh Victorious or Victor victorious I
think uh back on Nickelodeon and I was a
guest on that show because my daughter
loved that show she was you know a fan
of the show so I I did the show
basically so my daughter could meet
everybody on the show and and it was a
fun time we had a blast and she was in
uh Ariana
or
uh uh I just blanked on her name it it
doesn't matter Arana Grande Arana Grande
yes Ariana Grande um uh she was very
nice no I know her name I just blanked
on her for a second but when you were
working with her did you know her did
you say hey yeah absolutely I don't know
who you're no no no it was a whole it
was an ensemble cast but uh she was very
nice very nice very nice very nice yeah
she have you seen The Breakfast Club uh
I I I saw part of it I think movie from
the I watched it with my daughter that's
a movie from the 80s were you in were
you no no no but the it was a the
episode we did on Victorious was a
parody of Breakfast Club basically they
were bunch of high school kids and I
gave them Saturday detention and I was
playing uh a jerk principle like the one
in uh Breakfast Club correct yeah she
did she did so good in that she
was she crushed that part it was awesome
to see that wait wait wait wait she
played I don't get that I'm not
understanding what the question is he
you went to a football you went to a
foot hoping that you would get to ask
this question question uhhuh that's
common a lot of people drive across the
country to ask what what the what I
think about Ariana GR in a particular
sketch yeah wait what do you mean
amazing she was amazing in that episode
specifically but just all around yeah
she's just really good she was she was
definitely a star on see what she was
like that was like right before her
first album came out was she like
singing or did she uh talk about that at
all the the week I was on set she didn't
sing um but uh she was pure joy to work
with as was the entire cast who all of
them pretty much went on to do great
things who I don't know I don't know the
cast of that show you wouldn't young
young actors very talented have you ever
met Ariana
Grande have I yes or any of the other
electricians in Dallas area me me and
Eric have not that's why I mean I'm I
think she's just absolutely amazing so
that's why I I wanted to see what what
she was like I hope to meet her one day
I really like that's a goal of
mine so all right well well I I can
vouch for the fact that she's really
really talented and very very nice oh
that is that is so good to hear
yeah that was that worked out well thank
you thank you DK do you have anything
else to ask
Rob did she I just she TI her hair
constantly that did she say anything
about that or say anything about I'm
sorry D what was it say anything hair
her hair like theed no what ask the
question ask the question again she so
she dyed her hair red in that show quite
a bit I was just wondering if there's
anything like onset with her talking
about that or if your opinion do you
like her better red or her natural hair
color now uh uh uh she can she can pull
off anything uh her natural hair color
though is is the way to go always and uh
uh she never talked about uh her hair
while we were on set oh okay okay well
thank you that's great information that
was that makes me very happy to hear all
that thank you very much Rober good
absolutely all right thanks again
Derek Derek should I hang up Derek
should I hang up did he go are you still
there yeah we're there oh okay thank you
thank you guys so much thank you for
having me yeah yeah absolutely good
night lovely so uh Derek who friend Eric
uh engineer electric electri
electricians in the Dallas Fort Worth
area yeah passionate about area on a
grande um and uh I feel like I'm I know
made the GU day I feel like I really
gave you really did he's been chasing
he's been chasing Rob rle since when
when did you do this
I did the it had to be like 12 years
[Music]
ago it had to be I mean at least a
decade it's been over a decade over a
decade and this guy he's been way well
he appreciates the work I see that I get
[Music]
it